I cannot currently recall a movie about
women being more manly this movie sounds
okay
bridesmaid stars Kristen Wiig Maya
Rudolph Rose Byrne and I'm gonna have a
postive Wendi mclendon-covey Ellie
Kemper Melissa McCarthy Chris yeah I and
some other people too it's about a group
of women who are barking upon a quest to
help their friend get married and it's
basically like the week or so leading up
to the wedding and it's a whole bunch of
stuff happens basically because Kristen
Wiig character she's very neurotic you
know she's very you know she's not very
assured in life she has a lot of
problems she has a lot of failing
relationships and she doesn't really
understand where she fits in and the
only thing she really has is this best
friend relationship with with Maya
Rudolph's character who's getting
married and when Rose burns character
kind of comes in the middle of that and
starts being the new best friend she has
a lot of hardships trying to figure that
out because you know all she really has
in her life that's solid is this one
best friend all crap breaks loose lots
of comedy slapstick and absolute
insanity ensues a lot of great comedy
comes out of this and I honestly loved
bridesmaids it's actually one of my
favorite moves of the year so far
Kristen Wiig is excellent in this movie
she's not too over the top there's a lot
of emotion in her character it's not
just just the funny comedy there's a lot
of depth to her character you really
feel her as a person having seen
Something Borrowed last week and
watching Kate Hudson and Jennifer
Goodwin plow through a movie in which
their characters were cardboard cutouts
of women people who are medically to
advanced a fake film along
that does not have any respect for women
whatsoever here we have a movie that
treats the female characters like people
they actually seem like they're living
people movie actually respects women
because it allows them to be what
Hollywood doesn't generally portray
women to be it makes them seem more like
guys and I've known a lot of girls who
are like this who are just you know very
laid-back they're not all feminine or
you know prissy or anything let women be
themselves they're then put a barrier on
you know how women are supposed to act
you know by normal standards so I really
like that I know I'm sounding gay right
now this movie is so sharply written the
comedy is just so biting in this movie
it's so huge sometimes the comedy like
stuff like Wow about it's embarrassing
kind of like how meet the parents you
know had a lot of embarrassing comedy at
the same time it seems real
I had a few issues with the movie and
basically it comes from a romantic
subplot that Kristen Wiig character has
you have a really intense funny and an
even dramatic relationship between her
and her best friend and this problem
that she has with Rose burns character
where they're fighting him lots of
catfight stuff that this separated part
where she's you know meeting this guy
this police officer I just felt like it
was kind of added baggage and I can
understand why it helped her character
to have something good you know to to
back up on besides what was going on
with her friend besides that I love this
movie really hilarious movie really good
performance is all around a movie that
allows women to flourish not just to
keep them restricted to the confine you
know Hollywood standards of what female
comedy should be like this is honestly
nowhere near chick flick it's called
bridesmaids it stars a whole bunch of
women but men and women will enjoy this
movie alike bridesmaids three and a half
out of four stars one of my favorite
comedies I've seen in a while and one of
my favorite movies of the year so far
it's about a group of women who are
embarking upon a stinking semi-truck